hola
[Música]
antes de iniciar esta charla me gustaría
que pudieran preguntarse
cuál fue el último libro o texto que
leyeron
lo tienen
ahora bien cuál fue el último texto o
libro escrito por una mujer que leyeron
en el 2019 y como mujer investigadora
puede hacer de estas preguntas fue
desconcertante para mí darme cuenta de
que como estudiante no estaba leyendo
mujeres y también me encontré con esta
gran ausencia en la bibliografía de mis
cursos de derecho y de relaciones
internacionales
en este contexto con muchas preguntas y
pocas respuestas fue que nació la
propuesta mujeres en la bibliografía
pero para entender que es mujeres en la
bibliografía me gustaría que nos
remitiéramos a lo dicho por bertol
brecht un poeta alemán en su poema
preguntas de un obrero que lee y es que
en este poema berto el break nos hace
una serie de cuestionamientos sobre la
forma en cómo entendemos la mal llamada
historia universal y es que cuando
hablamos de la historia universal en
realidad se trata de una historia llena
de vacíos donde nos cuentan algunos
hitos de la historia de la humanidad
pero no nos cuentan por ejemplo quiénes
fueron los obreros que estuvieron detrás
de las grandes construcciones quienes
fueron los que pusieron los muertos en
las grandes guerras y quienes pagaron
los costos me permito leerles entonces
algunos extractos extractos
quien construyó te vas la de las siete
puertas en los libros aparecen los
nombres de los reyes
arrastraron los reyes los bloques de
piedra y babilonia destruir a tantas
veces quien no volvió siempre a
construir
el joven alejandro conquistó a la india
el solo césar derrotó a los galos no
llevaba ni siquiera cocinero
felipe de españa lloró cuando su flota
fundida no lloro nadie más
ahora bien sigamos haciendo las
preguntas han visto esta fotografía
es la fotografía oficial de la quinta
conferencia soy rey de 1927 de las 29
personas investigadoras y científicas
que aparecen en esta fotografía al menos
17 serían galardonados o ya habían sido
galardonados con algún premio nobel
aparecen posando en esta foto las
personas científicas más brillantes de
la época y podemos encontrar los rostros
como los de albert eisntein niels bohr
erwin schrödinger max planck y marie
curie como pueden notarlo marie curie es
la única mujer en esta fotografía y ya
para ese momento había sido merecedora
del premio nobel de física en 1903 y del
premio nobel de química en 1911 pero
porque a marie curie era la única mujer
en esta fotografía es que acaso habían
otras mujeres científicas en esta época
a las que no invitaron o sólo nos
salieron en la foto
como consolidan las personas
investigadoras su carrera y que quienes
tienen que sacrificarse para que estas
carreras sean exitosas
qué pasa cuando la mitad de la humanidad
las mujeres no figuran en la historia
universal como entendemos los grandes
avances científicos las discusiones
filosóficas y sobre todo a quién se los
atribuimos
todas las preguntas nos permiten
entender la forma en cómo se construye
el conocimiento científico la educación
en todas sus etapas se enseña de forma
sexista y excluyente
esto significa lo que donna haraway nos
decía para quien mientras que la voz y
las palabras han sido siempre del hombre
la carne ha sido de la mujer
esto tiene consecuencias sobre la forma
en cómo se crean los conocimientos
científicos porque desde la filosofía
griega se consideraba que las mujeres no
teníamos la capacidad de pensar antes
bien al igual que la naturaleza
estábamos para hacer dominadas y la
consecuencia de esto es que el silencio
de las mujeres nuestro silencio es uno
de los pilares de la civilización
occidental
pero si este de la nación a lejana qué
consecuencias tiene para nosotros y
nosotras bueno la consecuencia más
evidente es que hay miles de narraciones
historias y experiencias que no
conocemos sencillamente porque no nos
han sido tontas contadas y no hablo de
pocas experiencias hablo de las de la
mitad de la población mundial
esto sin mencionar otras poblaciones
históricamente marginalizadas como las
poblaciones afrodescendientes o los
pueblos indígenas para quienes la
ciencia se ha acercado a robar sus
conocimientos ancestrales
estamos ante una problemática que no
puede ser ignorada no mientras la
ciencia se siga considerando objetiva y
rigurosa porque no puede ser objetiva y
rigurosa cuando se basa en el
silenciamiento de las mujeres como parte
de mis reflexiones me di cuenta que a
pesar de que las mujeres superan vamos
en número a la cantidad de hombres
estudiantes seguían siendo carreras
absolutamente masculinizadas yo tenía
que seguir agravando mi voz para hacerme
escuchar
tenía
además que ocultables toda mi
sensibilidad y tenía que seguir citando
autores para recibir el reconocimiento
de mis profesores del curso de modo que
dedicara una campaña electoral en la que
fue candidata a representante
estudiantil en el consejo universitario
de la universidad de costa rica el tema
me pareció impostergable y fue así como
coloque en el plan de gobierno un hombre
que aunque pudo haber sido más original
reflejaba exactamente el espíritu de la
propuesta y decidí que debía llamarse
mujeres en la bibliografía
esta propuesta nace con tres objetivos
el primero de ellos era generar acciones
afirmativas para revertir las
inequidades de género dentro de los
espacios universitarios
el segundo era hacer notar los sesgos de
género presentes en la academia que
impiden la rigurosidad de lo que se
estudia y el tercero tiene que ver con
la generación de una comunidad
científica plural diversa heterogénea y
aquí no nos referíamos únicamente a la
participación de las mujeres sino a
muchísimos otros sectores que en este
momento ni siquiera tienen la
posibilidad de acceder a los espacios
universitarios
una de las cuestiones que más me
preguntan cuando acudo hablar sobre esta
propuesta es cómo surgió
y siempre ha intentado encontrar una
respuesta que cautive pero al mismo
tiempo se corresponda con lo que en
realidad pasó y la verdad es que como
hoy estamos en confianza voy a decirles
que la respuesta menos sofisticada pero
más real es que solo se me ocurrió pero
como no se me va a ocurrir si hace no
más de un siglo las mujeres tenían que
utilizar nombres masculinos y seudónimos
para publicar sus investigaciones
si los sexismo los prejuicios y la
discriminación no permiten a millones de
mujeres y niñas al estudio de las
ingenierías y de las ciencias porque se
les dice que no son para ellas y esto
solo por mencionar los rasgos más
evidentes pero también hay otra serie de
realidades más sutiles pero igualmente
alarmantes que suceden y por las que las
mujeres no tienen el mismo acceso según
york times' existen diferencias en la
participación entre hombres y mujeres en
los espacios académicos
entonces mientras que los hombres
tienden a hablar más tienden a ser más
intervenciones e incluso más
interrupciones las mujeres nos cuidamos
más somos buscamos no gastar más tiempo
es necesario
somos más autocríticas e incluso somos
indirectas con el fin de agradar
en las aulas también existen diferencias
en cuanto a la participación entre
hombres y mujeres los hombres hablan
nueve veces más en promedio que las
mujeres además son quienes tienden a
levantar más la voz y además son quienes
más participan
con ponencias e investigaciones en los
espacios académicos
y ahora me gustaría contarles cuáles
fueron las reacciones que tuvo este
proyecto como todo debate era de
esperarse que existieran diversas
reacciones
afortunadamente la mayor cantidad de
reacciones fueron muy positivas nos
encontramos con un profesorado receptivo
dispuesto a la propuesta y hacer
modificaciones en sus programas de los
cursos
pero su por sobre todo me encontré con
colectivas con organizaciones de mujeres
dispuestas siempre acuerpar e incluso me
encontré con profesoras que enviaron sus
escritos a medios de comunicación
institucionales para sumarse a la
discusión y defender la propuesta a
estas mujeres todo mi agradecimiento
fueron
la confirmación de que los resultados y
las transformaciones sociales sólo
suceden en colectivo
pero por supuesto también reacciones
incómodas y reacciones negativas o desde
argumentos que hablaban de que esta
propuesta iba a implicar el fin de la
ciencia y acá yo me pregunto si se
refieren a esa misma ciencia que se
nutre del silencio de las mujeres
hasta argumentos que denotaban un
profundo desprecio por los artículos
escritos por mujeres y esto también puso
en evidencia otro fenómeno y es la
comodidad académica desde la cual hablan
algunos investigadores
para muchos una vez que se logran
asegurar un lugar desde el cual hablar
éste se convierte en una licencia para
opinar sin entender escribir sin leer y
hablar sin escuchar
y acá me gustaría mencionarles el tema
de la violencia contra las mujeres
porque cuando hablamos de violencia
contra las mujeres no necesariamente nos
referimos a las manifestaciones más
evidentes y groseras la violencia contra
las mujeres sucede de muchísimas formas
una de ellas es la violencia académica
contra las mujeres
comprendo que para quienes no vivencian
los dolores de la exclusión puede ser un
poco difícil entender esto es decir para
quienes nunca han sido silenciados o
para quienes no han sido desmerita dos
por su trabajo sin embargo lo que les
propongo hoy es que podamos tener
empatía con otro tipo de realidades
esta propuesta también significó un
ejemplo del poder transformador de las
juventudes y una muestra de que las
agendas de las juventudes no son
únicamente sectoriales sino que buscan
trastocar a todos los sectores de la
sociedad de pronto una actividad que
parecía exclusivamente docente no lo fue
tanto y nosotras empezamos a exigir que
los cambios en la docencia pasaban por
las personas estudiantes en este sentido
se dirigen en el día de hoy pude romper
con el monopolio de las palabras de los
saberes y de las luchas
mi invitación el día de hoy se dirige a
que apoyen no sólo esta iniciativa sino
muchas otras encaminadas a erradicar las
disparidades de género a que surjan
nuevas iniciativas ya que por supuesto
hagamos lo propio para que en cada
charla taller o conferencia las mujeres
hablen más escriban más publiquen más y
aparezcan más mi invitación es a
rediseñar la historia para que en esta
nueva versión que construyamos las
mujeres también podamos ser las nuevas
protagonistas
en conclusión mujeres en la bibliografía
fue una propuesta encaminada a hacer
notar las diferencias de género dentro
de la academia pero el hecho de que esto
surgiera en un espacio universitario ya
nos habla de una de sus limitaciones
los sesgos de género no empiezan en
instancias avanzadas sino muchísimo
antes es algo que sucede en nuestras
escuelas en nuestros colegios y en
nuestros hogares me refiero a un
problema estructural que incide sobre la
crianza de las niñas sobre el fomento de
sus capacidades ya está en una etapa
sobre el reconocimiento que las mujeres
reciben en la bibliografía de los cursos
pero antes de que las mujeres puedan
seguir siendo leídas visibilizadas y
reconocidas tenemos que asegurar que
accedan a los espacios educativos y
sobre esto la tarea que nos queda aún
pendiente es monumental muchísimas
gracias